بعد انتهاء الناخبين الاتراك من الادلاء
باصواتهم واغلاق الصناديق الاقتراع تنفتح
ابواب السيناريوهات للفوز بكرسي الرئاسه
صحف تركيه رجحت اربعه احتمالات احدها فوز
اردوغان بفارق مريح وعندها سيكون التصويت
الايدولوجي قد لعب الدوره الابرز لمصلحه
حزب العداله والتنميه المحافظ ما قد يشكل
اعداما سياسيا لمرشح المعارضه كمال وفي
حال فوز مرشح المعارضه ستنتهي فتره قياده
اردوغان لتركيا التي استمرت اكثر من عقدين
وحينها سيكون العامل الاقتصادي هو المؤثر
الابرز في حسم التصويت لكن اذا فاز
اردوغان بفارق ضئيل سينفتح الباب لمواجهه
قد تصل الى قاعات القضاء اما في حال عدم
تحقيق اي من المرشحين البارزين نسبه الفوز
سيتم اللجوء الى جوله اعاده